I started taking H-M-E-T, I think that's called H-M-E-T binder, supplement to bind microtoxins.
I've noticed my urine is murky brown color similar to the color of H-M-N-H-M-E-T.
Is this to be expected while taking it, do you have any suggestions on how long to take
it, taking two capsules per day, they'll be enough for 60 days.
I don't know, quite honestly, there's lots of different reasons why your urine could be discolored,
and it certainly could be due to that supplement, especially if there's more direct correlation,
I've never had this before, I started taking the supplement and immediately noticed a change in the color of my urine.
It certainly could be excreting microtoxins, understand H-M-E-T binder is not going to be solely specific to microtoxins,
so you could be binding other toxins and poisons as well, so I would say that this is probably a good sign.
So the other thing that could make your urine darker color is B vitamins.
So, I don't know if your diet has increased your B vitamins, that's another possibility, but there's other things as well.
I would say you take it for at least 60 days.
The amount of time it takes to get rid of microtoxins in your body depends on A, the rate of your detoxification,
but it also depends on B, the quantity of microtoxins that you have, and C, maybe most important to deal with is if you have current exposure.
So, I'll give you an example of current exposure, person did microtoxin test, knew that there was mold in this townhouse that they were living in,
had the townhouse that they were living in, completely redone and cleaned by mitigation outfit that was contracted to mitigate mold.
Down to it, they felt like dealt with everything in the townhouse. However, none of the neighbors wanted to get their toes checked.
Of course, you're living with walls that are connected walls, you can't obviously tear out sheet rock necessarily in a townhouse.
I don't think they went to that extent.
So, and then they retested six, I think it was about three to six months later, I don't know.
And they had different elevated microtoxins, so they had current exposure.
So, it's really hard to get better if you have current exposure, so that's why I highly recommend if you have elevated microtoxins to get your space tested.
And through that immunolytic slab, and if you want information on the immunolytic slab, go to our blog post again and look up, just start searching mold and it said, I think the blog post says inexpensive mold testing for your home.